in our very first episode we recommended
buying a used car with cash as the most
financially sensible option but for many
people that's just not possible the
majority of Americans Finance their
vehicles with loans and with Rising
prices and Rising interest rates car
loans are getting more expensive than
ever the average interest rate on a new
car jumped from 4.4 percent to seven
percent in just the last year the amount
that Americans now owe on cars has
doubled since 2011 making up over nine
percent of total U.S Consumer Debt you'd
think that this might be a good time to
forego buying and lease a car instead no
debt no commitment and lower monthly
payments than a car loan they can seem
attractive at first but lease agreements
have plenty of financial pitfalls and
are just as vulnerable to price and
interest rate hikes as buying they're
not always a bad idea ultimately it
depends on what matters to you and how
much you're willing to pay for it thank
you foreign
[Music]
the fundamental misconception about car
leases is that they work like other
rental agreements like for apartments or
furniture they don't cars are a unique
asset for one ugly reason depreciation
nothing costs so much yet it loses value
so fast as a car except maybe time
shares or Bitcoins and Lease Agreements
are designed to account for that here's
how it works if you wanted to lease a
new car for the typical term of 36
months the dealer will take the selling
price of the vehicle and subtract what
it's predicted to be worth in three
years known as the residual the result
is essentially the depreciation how much
value the car will lose while it's in
your possession which you are required
to pay off in monthly installments but
here's the kicker that amount is treated
like a debt just like a car loan you'll
pay interest and fees determined by your
credit score and often be required to
put up a down payment in this way a car
lease is less of a rental and more like
buying the most expensive years of a
car's life and because they depreciate
so quickly that can be close to half its
total value true it's less than the
sticker price so your monthly payments
are lower than a car loan would be for
an equivalent vehicle but when the lease
is up you have no asset to show for it
some lease agreements allow you to buy
the car at the end of the term at its
residual price but because leases tend
to have higher fees than car loans
you'll end up paying more than if you
had just bought it out right to begin
with another supposed advantage of
leasing a car is the freedom it affords
for those who are scared of commitment
it can seem exciting to swap Vehicles
every few years but leasing comes with
its own set of restrictions first of all
most lease agreements have a mileage
limit for the term of the lease usually
between twelve thousand and fifteen
thousand miles per year and if you go
over that you'll pay extra at a rate as
high as 50 cents per mile you can opt
for a higher mileage limit for a higher
monthly payment of course and you will
not be reimbursed for any miles you
didn't use second you must return the
vehicle exactly how you received it so
don't bother upgrading the stereo or
installing custom rims unless you don't
mind reinstalling the old ones before
you bring it back and lastly lease
Agreements are notoriously hard to get
out of early termination incurs
penalties that are sometimes as much as
the total remaining balance all at once
and unlike car owners you can't just
sell the vehicle if you don't want it
anymore you're pretty much stuck with it
until the term is over to be fair there
are some advantages to leasing a car
many lease agreements include routine
maintenance costs and newer cars are
typically still under a manufacturer's
warranty that's no small thing
considering car repairs are one of the
most common unexpected Financial crises
people have to deal with you'll never
have to go through the hassle of selling
it and if you own a small business
leasing a car can offer big tax benefits
unlike car loans in which you can only
deduct the interest lease payments by
businesses are fully tax deductible but
the main appeal of leasing is largely
psychological having access to a nice
new reliable car that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to afford the benefits
of comfort status and safety may not be
Financial but that doesn't mean they're
worthless what's the point of money if
it can't make us happy but are they
worth enough to overcome the cost I
think it's time to run the numbers
Michael and Ali are both in the market
for a car and each has room in their
budget for around five to six hundred
bucks a month with the same good credit
score Ali decides to buy a used car for
twenty thousand dollars he puts three
thousand dollars down and ends up with
36 monthly payments of about 540 bucks
Michael wants something fancier so he
decides to lease a new car with a
selling price of forty thousand dollars
which will lose about 40 percent of its
value over the three-year term he also
puts down three thousand dollars and
including interest and fees he'll end up
paying about 580 a month for 36 months
at the end of three years both men have
paid roughly the same amount of money
but their financial situation couldn't
be more different Ali now owns his car
free and clear and he can sell it for
probably half to two-thirds of what he
paid for it or he can drive it until it
falls apart which could be five to ten
years from now depending on how well he
cares for it Michael on the other hand
is right back where he started instead
of buying out the residual for twenty
four thousand dollars he opts to lease
another new car under the same terms if
we fast forward another three years
Michael will have paid about 25
000 more than Ali after a total of nine
years even if Ali has had to Shell out
ten thousand dollars in maintenance and
repairs he'll still be almost forty
thousand dollars ahead of Michael now
Michael isn't paying that money for
nothing he gets to Tool around town in a
brand new ride with all the amenities
whether that's worth it depends on what
matters to you but generally speaking if
you can't afford to buy a new car you
probably can't afford to drop forty
thousand dollars on a luxury either at
the end of the day inflation and Rising
interest rates haven't changed the math
on leasing if you have a car in working
order take good care of it and drive it
for as long as you can and if you're in
the market for a vehicle buying even
with a car loan still makes the most
Financial sense leasing provides the
short-term benefit of driving a nicer
car for lower payments but you're not
solving a problem just buying time and
that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
our very first episode still holds up
check out how cars keep you poor
[Music]